hello and welcome to our webinar on
combining records SPR systems with other
informative techniques on Phillip page
application scientist at Riker
analytical instruments today my
colleague dr. Mary Murphy and I will
briefly cover the theory behind SPR and
provide application examples of how
records SPR systems can be combined with
other instruments to provide a more
detailed characterization of
interactions of interest before we begin
discussing SPR I would like to briefly
introduce record and share some
information on our strong lineage
records heritage includes the design and
manufacture of instruments to determine
refractive index spending well over a
century our entrance into SPR
instruments began in 1997 with a
collaboration of Cornell University so
record has over 20 years of experience
and expertise and SPR our customers have
been very productive with the record SPR
systems in generating over 250 research
articles in peer-reviewed scientific
journals presenting their SPR data from
records SPR systems records SPR systems
cover the full spectrum of biomolecular
interactions including routine protein
protein interactions to more challenging
applications such as small molecule
protein interactions breaker also offers
a full line of services and support
options so you can get the most out of
your SPR experiments while meeting your
budget requirements record as hundreds
of SPR systems installed worldwide at
several key academic institutions along
with several biotech and pharma
companies a small sampling of records
installation base is shown here
record has to meaning SPR platforms a
two-channel and a four channel system
both systems implement high quality
optics and advanced electronics that
results in high sensitivity to carry out
demanding applications like small
molecule analysis the systems also
implement a robust Forex platform that
can accommodate different sample
compositions including crude samples
like whole cells lice aids and serum the
systems also have a high sample capacity
accommodating up to 768 samples for
higher throughput demands
Reichert also offers accessories to the
SPR platforms that can be added on at
anytime to increase your application
scope in addition we offer a range a
professional services to address your
research needs and budget requirements I
will now transition into talking about
the concept of SPR to induce the surface
plasmon resonance phenomenon a wedge of
polarized light spanning a range of
incident angles is passed through a high
index of refraction prism under total
internal reflection conditions the light
source implemented in records SPR
systems is a bank of light emitting
diodes operating at 780 nanometers in
this case the light for those LEDs is
totally reflected off the prism surface
and the reflected light is very intense
across the entire range of angles as
visualized by our photo diode detector
an SPR a thin film with an electrically
conducting metal
placed directly onto the prism in the
form of a metal coated glass chip gold
is readily used because it is the most
chemically inert metal that can give an
SPR signal from the visible wavelength
the polarized light impinges on the gold
ship an interface between two different
refractive indices the gold chip itself
and the medium above the gold chip
surface which is typically an aqueous
buffer the logic feel intensity for an
avid estimate wave is created has a
light impinges on the chip
this way penetrates into the gold
surface and is absorbed by the free
electron density clouds of the gold
medal this interaction generates a
saline electron density waves that are
bound to the gold chip surface called
plasmas this resonance of fact causes a
reduction in the reflected light
intensity with an energy minimum
occurring and a specific resonance angle
this residence angle is in turn
sensitive to changes in refractive index
occurring above the gold chip surface
hence the name surface plasmon resonance
or SPR for short
as was mentioned previously the SPR
phenomenon is brought about by shining a
polarized wedge of light onto a metal
surface that is at the interface between
two widely different refractive indices
this incident light can interact with
the electron constellations within the
gold causing a reduction in the
reflected light intensity seen as an
energy minimum by our photon detector
now if we envision tethering a
biological molecule such as an antibody
to the gold chip surface and that
introducing its binding partner the
energon will bind to immobilize antibody
and in turn call the change in
refractive index this changer effective
index causes the residence angle minimum
to shift to a different angle that is
proportional to the mass of the bow
material on the gold chip surface in an
SPR instrument this angle change is
converted to a response and record it as
a function of time known as a sensor
gram SPR instruments measure very
precise changes in refractive index at
the surface of the gold hunter' chip the
traditional unit of measure is a micro
riu or 10 to the minus 6 refractive
index units this corresponds to a change
in mass at the surface of 1 picogram per
millimeter squared the RMS noise level
of records SPR systems is point zero
five marker Riu
or equivalent to a mass change of only
50 thumb programs this high selectivity
in Able's
the monitoring of either very low
molecular weight molecules or the
binding of very few molecules of higher
molecular weights with great confidence
so basically we have is a very precise
mass sensor SPR can tell us many things
about how two molecules bind or interact
with one another simple tests can
quickly determine whether or not there
is binding and rank the relative body
level of many compounds for a screen
application more complex experiments are
able to characterize kinetics rate
constants or on/off rates data from
experiments for responses read to study
state is used to calculate the affinity
Costin SPR can also be used to determine
the concentration of biologically active
molecules in solution and also used to
calculate thermal dynamic Doni
parameters to reveal the mechanism of
the interaction yr chronics importance
mathematically the equilibrium
dissociation constant or affinity
constant symbolized by Kb defined as the
operate / on rate if we look at our plot
of the on rate versus the off rate we
can see that interactions are vastly
different on and off rates can have the
same equilibrium dissociation constant
in this example along a diagonal three
completely different interactions all
have a tenday no molar binding affinity
the lower inset shows a slow on rate
followed by a slow off rate while the
upper inset shows a fast
Honore followed by a fast offering these
interactions would provide the same
affinity but as we can see have widely
different kinetics rates are extremely
important in determining how biological
processes or pathways proceed then are
also extremely important in considering
the selection of drug candidates
records spr systems can investigate
interactions between and within all
classes of biomolecules including
proteins nucleic acids carbohydrates and
lipids in addition the systems have the
sensitivity to probe small molecule
interactions with these biomolecules
lastly micro systems can also be used to
study whole cell interactions such as
antibodies bind to cells or living
bacteria records spr systems can
routinely carry out traditional SPR
applications such as kinetic and
athenian measurements but have the added
capability to interface to other elma
local instruments to increase its
application spectrum the next series of
slides that we will show illustrate
examples of this namely with the novel
SPR set up called SPR plus which allows
for coupling to chromatography and mass
and mass spectrometry in addition we
will show how right let us PR systems
can be coupled to platter chemistry and
photo chemistry through writer it's
unique collection of flow cells there we
show our SPR plus system with the
addition of a pneumatic gradient from
flexible valve assembly and a fraction
collector the SPR plus system expands
the range of SPR applications into bio
processing and can save researchers
valuable time by allowing them to obtain
more pertinent information about their
analyzed under study
experimental methods for characterizing
the influence of solution conditions
such as pH and ionic strength Jim to
guide researchers with the opportunity
to make predictions about how these
variables will do full on solubility
phase behavior and eventual
crystallization this new spr system is
capable of processing prepard of amounts
of analyte and can be connected to
upstream or downstream analyzers like
LTE or mass spec and ifs example of all
the SPR pulse system can be applied we
show how using our flexible valve
assembly allows for the combination of
SPR with chromatography this combination
can be used as a screening tool to
analyze protein protein self
interactions and then the Paso's provide
results lightful seeing using self
interaction chromatography for SI see
what only using a fraction of the amount
of sample that si si does in this
schematic 2 micro columns are integrated
between the floor channels of our two
channel SPR system via our extended
field module you serve as reference milk
proteins and interaction monoclonal
antibody or lab activated column the
signal and the first SPR channel serves
as a control for possible variations of
the back pressure attacking density for
the to call the second channel
downstream of the columns registers the
retention time differences between the
two columns
so we show us some preliminary results
with this setup the same monoclonal
antibody that has called it on the
interaction column is injected as
analyte initial all related centigrams
to walk to this picture so typical
concentration dependent signals on the
first SPR flow channel this is before
the protein is in contact with either
the may have modified column or
reference call hence the first flow
channel of the SPR esters is a pre
column detector and shows no deviation
for replicate injections the antibody is
unpierced over the protein column in a
formulation boffer resulting in an
earlier retention time and what is seen
when the same animal sample is passed
over the reference column you see this
to the right on this picture we also
seen for the antibody peak on the
protein column versus the reference
column in the case of the formulations
offer is having a repulsive effect an
antibody self interaction in the case of
a formulations also that enhances self
interaction the protein would come later
although in its preliminary stages of
development this set up shows promise is
a novel way to predict antibody
aggregation using less sample and
traditional means perhaps ten to a
hundred times law in example two we
employ a gradient Association to
separate out good antibody from antibody
degraded by oxidation with peroxide we
use this example to show how the
structural integrity of humanized IgG
one class monoclonal antibodies a syrup
therapeutic interest can be
differentiated using SPF all
now we see a traditional traditional SPR
injections with isocratic buffer
we're antibody characterization a micro
column is filled with nab select egg
rolls suspended in PBS and nab select 13
was a mean coupled to it the running
buffer here was pH 7.4 PBS t wild-type
antibody and oxidized the end of values
were injected at a concentration of 100
micrograms per ml each for the content
titled 8 minutes these overlays as you
can see are all very similar all under
the wild-type antibody that is somewhat
larger binding response compared to the
samples oxidized with peroxide making it
virtually impossible to differentiate
between the different states of
observation however once a gradient is
applied to the dissociation step the
differences between the samples become
clearer using pbft APH 7.44 buffer 1 and
PBS DF p h2 for buffer to the granules
applied from 0 to 100% significant
differences in banding patterns between
wild-type and stress variants of the IgG
one become apparent using the gradient
Association loss the SGR cost could be a
valuable tool for monitoring the
structural integrity during upstream and
downstream process development of
therapeutic antibody
and our last example we show that FDR
applause can be used to combine SPR with
mass spectrometry in combination with
the fridge and collectors when estart
example the SDR plus system was equipped
with the pneumatic pump auto sampler
availed manifold including a micro
column and the freshen collectors so
mica column was filled with the M
sephadex C 50 and was placed between the
two flow channels of the two SPR
spectrometer the SPR sensor chip uses
dextran FC RN or neonatal FC receptor
was immobilized onto both channels and
the like a poem by I mean coupling with
EDC NHS
next an antibody mixture at a
concentration of 200 micrograms per
milliliter was injected for three
minutes and then dissociation was
carried out for eight minutes to
received to the loss of this small slide
ration collection status in the last
minute of the dissociation phase and
fractions were collected at regular
intervals indicated by vertical lines in
the schematic ever lost each collected
fraction was subsequently treated and
then analyzed by electrospray ionization
mass spectrometry in the figure on the
right we see a decrease in the responses
of the two times oxidized variant of the
antibody is additional fractions are
analyzed hence using this example we
show that it is possible to resolve
incline of five individual molecular
species and sample mixtures using the
sqlplus settle in addition benefit of
combatting SPR analysis miniaturised
affinity chromatography is that it leads
to lower sample consumption in the
subsequent ms analysis step
I will now show an example of how
records to kennel SPR platform can be
combined with an electrochemical
technique to create an electrical sensor
for detecting new travellin in this work
a mix officer model layer containing a
mixture of positively charged oolagah
licen peptides and triethylene glycol
terminated thiols was deposited on the
on a plain gold chip surface
specifically the algal icing peptides
have a bio active molecular Moyle
Lyautey biotin conjugated to them that
can be reversibly concealed or exposed
as a function of surface potential in
this case the algal lysine pup hi serves
as a swishing element while the biotin
serves as the recognition element and
the vowel group provides the attachment
point to the gold chef surface the graph
shown here illustrates the binding of
nutri avidin to the biotin oligopeptide
surface under open circuit or OC
conditions neutral and binds fairly well
to the violations surface as indicated
by a strong binding response however as
a potential is increased to point three
wolves we see that the buying response
so that clearly increases which shows
even greater nutrient and binding as
compared to OC conditions perversely
when a negative potential is applied the
neutrality of bonding diminishes
substantially where very little to no
nutrient binding is observed this result
showed that nutrient and binding can be
subtly tuned by altering the surface
potential on the center chip surface
to address the question if the
switchable surfaces undergo reversible
dynamic conformational changes induced
by a surface potential a switching cycle
between a bio active state and bio
inactive state was monitored by SPR as
seen in the graph shown on the slide
PBS buffer was initially flowed over the
biotin a legal license peptide mix-ins
under OC conditions then the biotin
peptide mixed amp surface was exposed to
the potential of minus 0.4 volts and a
new travelling solution followed by
release of the electrical potential and
returned to OC conditions while the
nutrient solution was still passing
through the system when a surface
potential switched from being under OC
conditions to being under a bio inactive
state and neutral evident is introduced
over the surface as expected
minimal protein binding was observed
return of the surface to a bio active
state induces an immediate and immediate
and large increase in neutral Abbadon
binding these resolve show that the
develop switchable surface allows
reversible control of biomolecular
interactions the ability to regulate
biomolecular interactions on surfaces
driven by an external stimuli is of
great theoretical interest and has
practical impact in the biomedical in
biotechnology fields now I will show an
example of how the record to channel
system can be combined with photo
chemistry using Rikers exclusive optical
quartz middle flow cell to observe the
photo isomerization of a nasal benzene
derivative
in this study the series of easel
benzene derivatives were investigated to
undergo his trans isomerization when
illuminated with UV or blue light
specifically the role of the linker
molecule between the asel benzene and
that alkane file unit was probed to
determine the optimal linker length for
the azo benzene Sam surfaces it was
found that the Astra linkage exhibited
pronounced photo isomerization so mix
sham surfaces with this linker and AD
butene file were created the mixed Sam's
of n butane file were produced to reduce
tarik hindrance an STM image of this Sam
surface shows a stripe like structure
with homogeneous ly distributed approach
fusions that results from the easel
benzene molecules being colloids orb
within the butane file Sam the graph
shown here shows the SPR response when
the Sam surfaces was exposed to UV and
blue light which was provided by Ana
secondary light source they can
illuminate the gold chip surface using
records exclusive optical flow cell and
it seemed from the data the trance its
isomerization process was reversible
once between the illumination wavelength
from UV to blue and vice-versa
additionally the transits isomerization
process follows first-order kinetics and
the actual kinetics or rate constants
can be determined by using SPR
the results show a strong dependence on
a molecular structure of the absorbance
the mix amps were created with an
butanol to reduce steric hindrance the
pholis op the folo isomerization process
follows first order kinetics and a time
constants calculated indicate high
quantum efficiencies on the same order
of magnitude as compared to those of the
molecules in the solution final
application is another different example
of all spr can be used in combination
with mass spectrometry just pairing a
long user to study kinetics and also to
determine the identity of what is
binding in a mixture the SBR used is our
automated two channel model which can be
coupled to any mass spectrometer via the
developed interface work on the
interface has been carried out by
Professor Michael
Podolski street at the steinbier Center
in Germany the coupling schematic for
this application is shown here this
shows a workflow for epitope and
affinity analysis using an online SP RMS
analyzer after sample injection item 1
the analyte is captured on the affinity
chip item 2 followed by the spi chip
item and 3 for a kinetic analysis of the
affinity interaction after sample
passing through the defaulting interface
items 4 & 5 structural analysis is
performed by ESI electrospray ionization
mass spectrometry shown as item 6 years
total experiment time is about 70
minutes
carousel one example of how the online
sPRM aspect is used for epitope
identification and affinity
determination of a beta specific
antibodies related to Alzheimer's
research to identify the epitope which
is that part of the antigen that is
recognized by the immune system the a
beta auto antibody was immobilized on a
Dexter and SP RF enemy chip and a
triptych mixture of a beta peptide
fragment was injected over it subsequent
online default tune of analyzed prior to
MS was contracted performed the after
illusion of affinity captured a beta
peptide which provided identification of
a beta 17 through 28 there's the epitope
peptide did if ufn be determined by SBR
was 3.56 nanomolar
plus the combination of SBR and mass
spectrometry there's a number of
possible applications including
biomarker evaluation yet epitope
determinations along with precise
antibody affinity characterization and
direct label free antigen quantification
it includes pink occlusion record lots
of your partner every step of the way
record has unmatched customer service
and a variety of support solutions to
address your research needs and budget
record also a systems that maximize
uptime to drive better results Riker
also can help you solve your research
bottlenecks as our systems are scalable
to meet your research needs as well as
your budget your budget requirements the
systems generate reliable binding
kinetics concentration of thermodynamic
data to help you answer questions
quantitatively in addition Rutgers SPR
systems increase your sample flexibility
you can study a wider range of samples
such as serum whole cells and life sites
and you can also combine a spear and
other techniques as you saw in is
laminar records SPR systems also reduce
your equipment and maintenance costs
keeping the running costs reasonable so
thank you very much for your time and
attention and we are happy to address
any questions that you may have thank
you again